[Music]
antagonist is introduced with a shot of
their feet cliche
leaving the key in the thermostat also i
can see how this could be an effective
interrogation tactic but we never see
anyone even break a sweat in this
episode hell jake has a jacket on the
majority of the time
and captain holt is wearing a tuxedo
who's this this
is phillip davidson it wouldn't be an
episode of bnn without peralta
expositing a new character in case to
hold isn't holt like the captain here
shouldn't have briefing notes on all
this stuff
we want to bring this guy down we have
to get him to confess right here
right now but philip hasn't been
arrested he's just been asked to come
down by peralta there's really not a
legal timetable here they've already 48
hours that scenario
here peralta just wants to close the
case asap oh
damn hello kevin i won't be joining you
there we're going
already the ticket's under my name h-o-l
is there a show on tv with better
weekend weak-out cold opens than
brooklyn nine-nine i think not
you're right he did it rush to judgment
much you have no murder weapon witnesses
or forensic evidence i get that the
episode is doing a thing here but this
is exactly the kind of arrogance that
has led to some awful real world
situations so what's in here feels
appropriate
who found the body hikers you're really
gonna just blow past the bear semen
detail captain holt might but we won't
in fact i'm probably spending way too
much time thinking about it but
sit on me is still a sin on you you know
good cop bad cop crazy cop sane cop
fast talking street wise cop and hong
kong cop aka the rush hour
you forgot soon to be problematic cop
too old for the cop peralta you're
slipping
hello phillip philip detective this is
captain raymond holt two men in adina
hey cap who's the scariest person you've
ever gotten a confession out of connie
buttons
okay thought it was gonna sound a little
cooler i actually did a quick google
search of connie buttons because i
thought as smart and fun as this show is
there's probably some connection to
reality with that comment and there
wasn't but i did get led to a two-minute
tuesday tip video about creating faux
colored buttons and that's two minutes
of my life and five ruined buttons i
will never get back
like great tiger for mike tyson's
punch-out he could teleport around the
ring has ever been a more popular game
that has become as problematic in as
many different ways as punch-out i mean
that's not a fault of the show but feels
like a huge sin
and i don't have anywhere else to put it
so you just punch him when he gets dizzy
sure to make him dizzy you have to wait
for him to teleport and then time your
blocks perfectly punching him when he is
dizzy is the easy part plus if you're
smart you can beat him without ever
letting him do the teleport punch if
you're going to brag about your
punch-out skills at least brag about the
right things
i know and i apologize but i'm executing
a strategy
generally something best discussed ahead
of time but the show needs us to find
this information out as we go so instead
we get this wonderful explainer
stupid questions grammatical errors lose
your train of thought
ooh relate everything back to those
movies you've seen tv since training
seminar somehow ends up in a brooklyn
nine-nine script hold on
i need to deal with it holt's phone
doesn't vibrate or chime and yet he says
hold on before even turning it over and
looking at it i mean we know this is a
ruse but you probably shouldn't give
that away to the suspect
this seems like a huge waste of time but
here you go
robert drove a sob dana's head was
blonde character shows intelligence by
quickly reciting a list of things we
thought they couldn't remember cliche i
mean i've watched planet earth
with the british narrator this sin is
for not mentioning david attenborough
put some respect on that name
so your uncle owns a cabin in the town
that the body was found that is quite a
coincidence
is it though i mean i guess it's weird
since it ties the suspect there but
considering it really has nothing to do
with the outcome i would argue it's more
of a contrivance since it conveniently
gives peralta something to stick his
foot in his mouth with
later i get the philip can't hear them
but why would peralta and holt be having
what is clearly a discouraging
conversation where he can clearly see
them
no i want me to lie and for you to stand
behind me and say like three
oh damns when i really get cooking many
people have heard of chekhov's gun but
here we have the slightly lesser used
check off so damn
your gut or intestines is lower you
should point down here closer to your
pubis captain hole would be excellent at
pubisins
remember how angry i got about how fast
daenerys got from dragonstone to north
of the wall that was intense game of
thrones complaints before the final six
it was a simpler time wasn't it it's
been two hours since you were last in
there besides that 90 second strategy
power what else have you been doing
i was watching taxi tv what was on
filing highlight fallon highlights
another two hours the timeline may be
the craziest thing in this entire
episode did these [ __ ] go on to a
ruth's chris for a four-course pre-fix
meal or something when they should have
been questioning this guy
i know we live in a world where anything
can mean anything twitter
why would you put a hiring now poster up
for the nypd in the nypd
you screwed up and my client's leaving i
mean maybe why in the hell are you just
in here now what kind of lawyer isn't
present for the entire interrogation a
convenient television guy and that's who
i got and i'm not going to tell you
before i do it because it will be more
fun for the audience to find out as it
happens it's already in a patient's
mouth
sun oh damn
oh damn indeed you know brooklyn 99 gets
a ton of credit for being a very funny
and innovative sitcom what most people
don't seem to mention is how great of a
cop show it can be as well
fresh air with all those trash bags
surrounding the area i doubt it and does
this precinct not have a dumpster
root canal and by the looks of those
x-rays it's not gonna be pretty
did you know the cinemas in writers have
podcasts check out syncast and behind
the sins by searching for cinema sins
wherever you listen to podcasts
i just came from a six hour murder
mystery where i played the corpse
spoiler alert they think you did it the
opera
is it the one bugs bunny sings and
that's all folks
why do you call the predator it's a
nickname you know the data suggests that
it
tracks its prey exploits weakness seems
to
well enjoy it you filmed him
dying if that's what i do it's my job
i'd like to say that if you're seeing me
you're having the worst day of your life
and i spent my whole time in the corner
talking to this woman dana
there is no dana there is only a zoo
it's not like we're college professors
calling ourselves doctors
doctor doctor doctor doctor